every nation that's a coastal state
has some region of the sea floor that
falls within their territorial waters
and many countries including the us the
area that's underwater
exceeds the area that's above water
so huge amounts of nations areas and
regions are just really
unexplored uncharacterized we don't
really know what's there
we know less about our seabed than we do
about the surface of the moon or mars
only 20 of it has been mapped a map of
the sea floor could lead to all kinds of
discoveries
like new marine species and rare earth
minerals like cobalt that we need for
electric cars and mobile phones
the value of all the gold deposits alone
on the seafloor is estimated to be
around 150 trillion dollars
a map could also help us when tragedy
strikes malaysia airlines flight
370 disappeared from radar screens
mapping of the ocean floor is being
carried out problem is that the southern
indian ocean
is just so incredibly huge to me a map
is a
fundamental piece of understanding of
who we are where we are
where things are once you understand
something you start to value it more
when you start to value something that's
when you start to really think about
making it healthy and preserving it and
keeping it going
a map is the first step it's the basic
understanding
that you need to figure out where you
are
[Music]
oceans they cover over 70 of the planet
but most of what lies underneath is a
mystery
the sea floor is a really fascinating
landscape we don't
have a lot of data to describe the shape
of it in detail
but in places where we do there are
spectacular features there's
meandering channels with all kinds of
interesting topography there are canyons
there are seamounts mid-ocean ridges all
kinds of
things that we see on land that are just
basically hidden from us
by the water as it stands this is what a
map of the seabed looks like
all that black those are the parts we
haven't mapped yet
at present most people think that the
sea floor is actually mapped because
you'll see
a world ocean map and you can see some
shape of the sea floor
but most of that is based on prediction
roughly eighty percent of what you see
for the world ocean floor
is modeled based on measurements of the
sea surface height
and a computation based on gravity
[Music]
in 2017 the nippon foundation and the
general barthometric chart of the oceans
or jebco launch seabed 2030
it's a collaborative project to collect
and collate data ocean wide
and create a complete map of the
seafloor by the end of the decade
to do this would take one ship around
350 years at a cost
of up to 3 billion that's why data is
harvested by all kinds of vessels
from fishing boats to freighters because
there is so little data
it's important that vessels that
are capable and willing to acquire data
while
when they're just moving around the
ocean do so so we have a lot of data
that's collected during transits
there's a lot of academic requirements
to make data
publicly available there's industry data
that's starting to become more and more
available
there's government data so there's a lot
of different ways that this data is
coming in and it's a really
messy and challenging puzzle to put
together but what's exciting is that
it's a puzzle to put together
since seabed 2030 launched the area map
has risen to 20
and all the information collected is
freely available
the more data we have collectively and
other people can access
the the faster the discoveries are made
which really pushes forward our
understanding at a faster rate
than if you held on to that data and it
was only you with that data
things like machine learning and
artificial intelligence are also going
to kick in
in the next decade because with all this
data they'll be able to make connections
that
a lot faster than perhaps we would have
been able to which then
again feeds our human understanding and
also gives us new ideas
new ways of thinking of exploration
until the early 20th century mapping
technology was simple
usually a weight attached to a long rope
known as a lead line
after the titanic sank in 1912 explorers
proposed using sound waves to find its
hull in the north atlantic
this led to sonar the most common
technique used for mapping today
[Music]
operated by the schmidt ocean institute
the falco
is an 82 meter long research vessel
equipped with two multi-beam sonar
systems
that have helped deborah smith and a
team of other marine technicians
to map over a million square kilometers
of the sea floor
you know you go from somebody with a
rope with some knots to
sonar acoustics that is i call it math
magic but it is
incredibly advanced mathematical
technology
to be able to measure the distance and
time of travel of sound
on a moving ship multi-beam mapping
works by
using sonars so sonar is taking
sound and measurement of time so you
have a multi-beam sonar and it sends out
a ping of sound
that sound travels through the water
column hits the sea floor and comes back
to the ship and we measure
that time and we're able to calculate
the distance
each individual ping of sound has many
many beams so it looks like a giant fan
across the sea floor and that fan is
moving along the seafloor so you have
many tiny little beams going across and
they're traveling
along a track you can look at that data
and look at both the peaks and the
valleys and the highs and the lows and
sort of
create a three-dimensional image of the
seafloor
the accuracy of multibeam sonar really
depends on the water depth that you're
in
think of it like a flashlight beam and
if you're holding a flashlight and
you're shining it on the floor
the closer you get to the floor with
your flashlight the smaller that beam is
if you have 400 of these beams all
across so think of 400 people holding a
flashlight the closer they hold that
flashlight to the seafloor
the smaller your beam is which also
means the smaller that you can find
information
or data about so it really depends
on the depth of the sea floor in order
to see
how much you can define an object
this variation in depth means that
mapping resolution will range from 100
by 100 meters in shallow waters
to 800 by 800 meters in the deepest
parts of the ocean
which go down as far as 11 000 metres
remotely operated vehicles or rovs can
then be sent down to investigate seabed
features up close
we've just crossed the thousand meter
mark it's 4.6 degrees c
and now we're going to drive the rv down
at a higher rate towards the
sea floor on a recent mapping expedition
scientists on the falcore discovered a
500 meter tall coral structure
in australia's great barrier reef the
first to be discovered in over 120 years
a place that is incredibly popular well
visited well traveled
you know we're still finding new things
you don't know until you map it and so
until you get that sort of high
resolution picture
you don't know the sand waves or the old
riverbeds that used to be there or the
waterfalls off the side of a volcano
that used to be above the surface and
now is below the surface
it's a little bit of everything think of
let's say hawaii
or someplace where you see a volcano
above the water picture that below the
water
i'm really kind of obsessed with the
whole concept of scale here
although we can create 3d models and you
know kind of come up with these
visualizations it's not the same as that
feeling of looking out over this big
landscape
but i mean i think we'll get there soon
with vr and other kinds of technology
but
it's really spectacular to think about
especially with the familiarity that
some of us have with these features like
what it looks like we look out at the
ocean and it just looks flat maybe with
little bumps
we really don't think about all of this
that's underneath and it's
really an amazing landscape that's just
hidden from us
with more than 90 of the ocean deeper
than 200 meters
fleets of autonomous vehicles could make
the data gathering process
faster cheaper and safer and new
discoveries might help with exploration
of all kinds
i think the ocean can actually provide
us with huge insights as we go out into
space as well
and look for life and other kinds of
life forms i also think in this next
few years we will have a different kind
of access to the ocean because of
virtual reality
and augmented reality and so that will
allow us to sit
in our living rooms and really
experience what's under water in a
different way and see
this different alien planet
[Music]
please
you